اهلا بكم متابعين صباح العربيه طبعا محتاج
اعرف هذا الان من مشاهير الدوحه صابر
العوض مرحبا صابر حياك الله خطبت الانذار
يا صابر حياك الله صباح الخير اخوي فهد
حبيبي هذا والله من فضل ربه صابر حدثنا
اول شيء عندنا الدوحه
كيف حضرتك ااا قطعت الاف الكيلومترات انت
من محافظه مدني في السودان ووصلت الى
الدوحه ايوه والله انا يعني كان من زمان
حلمي انه احضر كاس العالم لما كاس العالم
في روسيا انا حلمي يحضر كاس العالم
فبعد الشهره فقلت يمكن تجيني دعوه احضر
كاس العالم فلما كاس العالم قرب يعني
كره القدم
ما شاء الله عندي صديقتي اسمها اسمها
نزلنا عندها هنا وما قصرت معي في الحياه
يعني هاي
صابر تحس انك مشهور اكثر في همم لما كنت
في السودان ولا
الاجواء المونديال هنا والجمهور اداك شهره
اكثر لا انا اشتهرت لما صفحات برشلونه كان
نزلت لي في صفحه الرسميه يعني ومن لما
هذاك بدات الشهره لكن الحين في هذه الايام
شهره كثيره
حبيت كره القدم رغم الظروف اللي تعاني
منها يعني صعبه يعني
انت انسان فلازم نقعد ضحكك على سبب نجاحك
يعني فديت كره القدم بمعانه كبير جدا يعني
ولا قدنا صعوبات كثيره
في الحركه في الاخر يعني انت قلت للرياضه
الفستايل تغنيني عن الجري في الملعب هي
رياضه الفرستال مو مو بالسهله يعني تحتاج
لكنها ما تحتاج جري وما في حد يجي يضربك
على رجلك ما في حد انت هنا الكوره وتبدع
طيب اعطيني مواقف كيف الناس بتطلبك في
الطريق
[موسيقى]
الله الله يا صابر
الله
لهذا الاداء المبهر اشخاص باطراف كامله لا
يستطيعون فعل ما نراه اليوم من الموهوب
صابر
ايوه لا لا تضحك
[موسيقى]
يا سلام يا سلام
كمل كمل مع الكاميرا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا لا نحن مستمتعين بهذا العرض وكان
بودنا نشاركم يعني ان شاء الله خير
ان شاء الله بعدين باستمرن كويسه عندكم
وحيد لاختهم ممتازه اصلا
ههه